avec volée une frappe bien sûr bonjour
allen bonjean pauline à la une de la
presse internationale bien sûr comme à
la une de nos journaux ce matin hélène
la découverte des corps de dizaines de
civils à abuja dans le nord-ouest de
kiev en ukraine ville reprise il ya
trois jours par l'armée ukrainienne à
l'armée russe des corps jonchant les
rues les routes des victimes aux mains
liées dans le dos et exécutés d'une
balle dans la tête ou dans la poitrine
l'ukraine accuse la russie de massacres
de civils et de génocide annoncé ce
matin le quotidien catalan la vanguardia
qui fait et apolline de possibles crimes
de guerre et de graves violations du
droit international humanitaire selon
l'onu
la presse internationale exprime son
indignation
l'horreur de butch à titre le journal
italien la stampa et la repubblica
pardon auquel le photojournaliste senti
palacios qui a été l'un des premiers
journalistes avait sur place dans le
sillage du retrait russe a confié son
sentiment d'avoir découvert je le cite
l'enfer à bout de chats et sa nette
impression que la mort de nombreux
civils étaient dues à des exécutions
sommaires
ce n'est plus une guerre c'est une
boucherie le quotidien français
libération prévient qu'il faut rester
prudent qu'il faut se méfier de
l'émotion et des images prises à chaud
en rappelant la sphère des vrais faux
charnier de la ville roumaine de
timisoara en 1989 mais que si ces
massacres sont avérés alors il faudra qu
en témoigner devant la justice
internationale est passée à la vitesse
supérieure des sanctions un appel qui
est d'ailleurs également relayée par le
quotidien suisse le temps chaque
hésitation chaque réticence à soutenir
l'ukraine de manière décidée se paiera
au prix fort en termes de vies humaines
à bout de chat aujourd'hui à mario paul
et dans tout le reste de l'ukraine
demain et reporte à la suivre à abuja
dans le journal de 9h30 l'union
européenne hélène annonce de nouvelles
sanctions contre contre la russie au
financial times cite l'engagement du
président du conseil européen charles
michel à soutenir l'ukraine et les ong à
rassembler les preuves nécessaires à
d'éventuelles poursuites devant les
tribunaux internationaux mais aussi son
engagement à mettre en place d oeuvre
des mesures plus punitive contre moscou
le quotidien britannique évoque
notamment la possibilité d'interdire les
ports de l'ue aux navires russes
davantage de restrictions à
l'exportation encore des embargos sur
les approvisionnements énergétiques que
telles que le charbon le pétrole et le
gaz
longtemps exigée depuis longtemps par
l'ukraine on le sait mais jusque là
refusé par certaines grandes économies
européennes ces menaces de nouvelles
sanctions sont évoquées également ce
matin par le journal russe kommersant
qui rapporte que le ministère de la
défense de la fédération de russie a
qualifié hier de provocations ses photos
et ses vidéos des exactions commises
dans la région de kiev commerçante qui
fait état également de commentaire
trouvé sur télégramme affirmant que
certaines victimes civiles de cette
région de kiev aurait été tuée je cite
par l'armée ukrainienne pour avoir
coopéré avec les troupes russes à la une
également ce matin damien ok on parlait
à l'instant la victoire du fidesz en
hongrie le parti de viktor orban qui
arrive nettement en tête des
législatives d'après réty vilaggazdasag
le premier ministre hongrois se dirige
donc vers un quatrième mandat consécutif
tout en conservant sa majorité des deux
tiers au parlement une victoire que
l'hebdomadaire attribue à la pandémie et
à la guerre en ukraine qui aurait permis
à viktor orban de jouer je cite sur la
peur de la maladie et de la mort est
d'apparaître aux yeux de ses
compatriotes comme un dirigeant défensif
aux états unis de new york times associe
cette victoire de viktor orban en
hongrie à celle du chef de l'état serbe
sortant aleksandar vucic qui revendique
lui aussi une victoire écrasante à la
présidentielle d'hier éclipsé par la
guerre en ukraine les élections de
dimanche en hongrie en serbie prolonge
les mandats des deux dirigeants
européens les plus favorables aux crèmes
la relève le quotidien américain qui
présente les deux dirigeants ces deux
dirigeants comme des populistes
renforcés par leurs contrôles écrasant
des médias et l'énergie bon marché de la
russie politique toujours mais en france
le premier tour de la présidentielle a
lieu non six jours dimanche prochain les
intentions de vote en faveur des
candidats dits anti système atteignent
hélène à un niveau sans précédent de la
croix fait état d'une tentation
protestataires qui pourrait profiter et
ou aux candidats des insoumis jean luc
mélenchon et à la patronne de
rassemblement national marine le pen
dans la dernière ligne droite de la
campagne marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon qui en sont à leur troisième
candidature paraissent profiter de
l'ambiance anxiogène note le journal qui
relève que les deux candidats on appelle
au peuple contre les élites et prône la
rupture avec le système libéral au delà
des différences fondamentales leurs
différences fondamentales sur le fond
comme sur la forme vous avez dit
anxiogène ans ne se quittent pas là
dessus celles qui auraient le sentiment
que ça ne tourne pas vraiment rond
pauline je recommande de jeter un cil
haslett qui a peut-être une explication
à ce phénomène
selon des scientifiques notre planète
elle même n'est pas tout à fait ronde
car elle est en fait légèrement écrasée
à ces pôles cette forme est dit oblates
c'est à dire à la fois sphérique et
légèrement aplatie aplati à et non pas
plate comme le croit parait-il pauline
9% des français parait-il c'est dingue
oblates quel beau mot merci beaucoup
hélène c'était la revue de presse à
demain on se retrouve juste après la
pause pour la suite de parra direct